reject for me personally reject is way
more than just the conference it's it's
a very special place with very special
people and they're all gathering here
and it's it's about much more than just
technology it's really about the people
that are here and that's very very dear
to my heart so reject chess used to be a
tiny community conference and it has
become a big conference over the years
now it's still run by people from the
community for the community and it's a
very special time this year because it's
the fifth anniversary and it's a big
celebration music they started as like
overflow conference to jay's calm you
give people a chance to reject it at
jess come to you or either ticket prices
or by like not getting accepted so this
is very good idea to get more people
into the community and give them a
chance to be part of a solo thing
actually this projector is the first
protect yes and we're celebrating a
birthday but unfortunately it's the last
one they're very sad about that but we
think it's time to move on and there are
also so many amazing things that went
out like started with the rejecters and
still going on so yeah it's time to make
room for them so it's the laughing and a
crying I this year reject